the business pleasure you are involved
in is the mandalorian which just kind of
exploded when it released last fall and
it looks fantastic
and then I saw the behind the scenes
footage and like I watch a lot of behind
the scenes documentaries and I like to
think I know how things are made but it
blew my mind
yeah the volume that you guys used and
the way that the the backgrounds are
being you know rendered in real time but
I didn't want to ask I mean you know
this project was so secretive when John
came to you how did he describe it what
was what was kind of what were the early
days on the manual we're in like
the methyl aura is the perfect film at
the perfect time because you have you
have a company like Lucasfilm and oil in
who are innovators and and constantly
pushing the boundaries you have someone
like John who was doing the same but
they I don't believe then worked
together specifically before this
project yeah so
when you have people that are
automatically hardwired to push
boundaries and and and and mix up the
status quo
and you have the technology with LED
panels that are becoming suitable you
have 3d gaming engines you have all
these elements that are they floating
their very minds nothing like this had
been together specifically like there
were things like on road 1 which
effectively was the genesis of our the
concept with um with Ireland you know on
road one we built the honess enzyme rig
one we built a kind of a volume the biz
around the spaceships we built a
horseshoe and a lead in a and up like
that we've effectively built the same
concept in terms of lighting but we
didn't have real-time 3d gaming engine
interaction we didn't have that because
that was remember that was 2015 even
though I ago like it's long enough ago
that the LED panels were 9 mil then and
now they're two point four I'm n
DeLorean so that's that shows you how
much the technology has progressed yeah
in that two and a half years or three
and a half years so when I met with John
about that we we spoke about what this
could be you know doing the Star Wars TV
show
could be very expensive you know it
could be prohibitively expensive because
Star Wars is requires a lot of prop
building and a lot of character building
and and so we wanted to with Ireland's
help be able to make it a financially
viable option to to solve all the
problems that you have with shooting a
blue stream blue screen environment and
if you go into a studio without a set
effectively you've got a blue screen
that's a deep a you have to light it of
what you think it should look like yeah
you don't have any reference of what the
background looks like we might have some
concepts but effectively your lighting
at what you think it should look like
you're framing it to what you think it
should look like
there's nothing real is you don't have
anything to cling on to and as
filmmakers we're all used to plea on
something like the difference between a
shot this here and there stuff that's
there is significant like the difference
between a feeling of an actor here
versus here is significant and when you
don't have any of that
[Music]
blue screen you don't need to grandal on
to visually it's very hard to do a good
job and so the like I said all those
elements those those balls that were in
the air were all shown to land around
the same time
we did a little test in I think June
before we started shooting in October
just to make sure that the concept would
work and it did you know there were
there were definitely people are going
hmm there are better ways to do this so
there are different ways to do this but
eventually this concept kind of went
through and you know it was a very
rewarding experience was very it was a
lot riding on
on Island sodas at that point a lot
riding on my shoulders a lot riding on
John shoulders because if this
technology didn't work there's a lot of
money invested in the hardware this
technology didn't work if we turn up on
day one everybody's done their job
costumes done their job everyone knows
their lines will turn up on day one it
does not work there is no plan B
you know there was if the if the power
didn't rat had chewed out the cable to
the power like we did all these problems
that could occur we were trying to get a
hint of in trying to preempt thankfully
that judgment
thankfully the worse did not happen and
we always had something to true it might
not be might even have a sound perfect
but we could always wrangle it it's
incredible and I think it's in keeping
with the spirit of Star Wars I mean Jude
George Lucas was breaking those
boundaries back when he was making a new
vote
I think motion control was something
that he kind of helped pioneer and stuff
and it was funny because we managed to
to show quite a few people through the
volume orange but before I had I had to
leave and go and print June before I
left to prune I said quite a few
filmmakers through the volume and turn
them how how it could work and what's
cool you know
I won't name drop at this point but I
could and I would sound pretty cool if I
could but the Georgia taking some photos
I think the Russo brothers and sub
George Lucas yeah so drunk George's name
so did comedy Meister George - and it
was so funny because only thought of
filmmaking and George is like yeah this
is good this is good
like he's so matter-of-fact about yeah
yeah of course it is like parallax yeah
absolutely
it's it's totally I mean I could see
that he could see it 30 years ago
yeah but 30 0 wasn't he a man you know
sparklin someone's eye it was it was
barely thinkable so I think he was kind
of like well 30 used to be late but but
fantastic congratulations on on
achieving you know what should be the
perfect setup
I mean bear in mind - this is version
1.0 right yeah there is this dissenters
this has a lot LED technology real time
gaming engine this has a lot of
potential on the future and I think that
people see the the making of then
DeLorean and I and I'm and I love when
people see it they they have their minds
blown because that was the intention but
I'm already in like version four in my
brain like where you know you've got
mill flats and you've got stages that
are maneuverable and like create a whole
range of set pieces with their
technology um I think I'm totally viable
and I would say watch this space because
it's only gonna get more interesting
well I know season 2 is wrapped was a
was the technology able to be improved
for that or they much the same thing
so season two I wasn't involved with
bars either one who took over we didn't
take oh that's a misnomer bears and I
worked quite closely it's a very
intensive thing as a DP because it's
involves lighting tree lighting loads
and in investigating any panels very
very very busy time in pre-production
there's something that hasn't been done
before like so that was a big part of
things so baz and i worked sort of hand
in hand a lot to to get that season done
so when I left he didn't took over the
reins and shut the remainder and then he
won season two but yes they did I
believe make some improvements there was
a couple of shape improvements that we
made that we learnt and I think they I
think I season one we had different
panels on the roof versus the wall based
on availability that was solved
the way it was mounted there were some
typical things that they solved as well
so yeah I believe they did make some
improvements
but again I mean you know I see a world
where every film almost every film will
use this technology in some way shape or
form be it from a 200 million dollar
blockbuster down to a two million dollar
independent movie using it for one
sequence that they a dry eye or a studio
that's already been built and they again
they're like a location so I believe
that when the technology kicks on and
gets widely adopted when people
understand what it can do I believe
it'll be used quite a lot it's
incredible I would be remiss if I didn't
ask what it's like to light the child or
baby Yoda and was there any idea at the
time that this character was just gonna
absolutely explode yeah it just became
that's entirely like there's the
mandalorian and then there's baby you
know it didn't fully surprise me I tell
you it
didn't surprise me I knew that it was
gonna be a thing my kids came to visit
the set and um I specifically made sure
that they did not see the child Oh
interesting because I knew first of all
the first thing that talk about when
they went back to school would be baby
odor and this is obviously six months
before it comes out and that would be a
disaster and also that they'd love it
and my daughter right now she's really a
bit annoyed with me about that because
she wanted to give baby get her a hug
and one day in the future it's like baby
I'm innocent it's like any any
prosthetic ultimately you know and in
John
John very cleverly kind of suggested and
suggesting recommending you know bit of
the back line on the fuzz in the child's
hair and like just little things to help
kind of make it less rubbery and more
more real yeah
one thing I am super curious about about
the volume what is the post-production
light because you said you know this was
six months before it came out you were
shooting and I know for George one of
the impediments for him and bringing a
live-action Star Wars series to life was
that it was just cost prohibitive and it
would take forever for the
post-production how much is done there
like in camera on set and what's the
post-production like in terms of
finishing out those effects in theory
most of it's done in camera you know
there
he probably needs to speak specifically
to the post supervisor I don't know
numbers um but I know for a fact again
when I was putting together a demo it's
the demo reel for the visitors that came
on sick that none of that was post
produced and it was all in camera and
the stuff that I was able to bring out
to show people people were like that's
straight off camera like it's literally
it's graded and that's it there's been
no um no post work done to it um you
know there are times where if you're
doing a wide shot you're actually seeing
the same in the volume that's in the
edges and the seam that's harp and there
were some very simple fixes that that
ILM had to do for a lot of it
but again you probably it's up to them
but but you can effectively edit a movie
in a TV show that's falling camera
there's no very little blue so you can
you can effectively watch the film watch
this the show before post-production
touched it and you've got a really good
idea of how it looks
that's crazy yeah they're really good
all they're doing is tidying up you know
that's that's the ultimate goal is that
all I have to do is tidy up the edges
that's awesome